pal gibson's off about he signed a
three-year deal in the off-season
simmons on here to uh begin the game and
here is matt theis
and this one's on the ground down to
first goose want a second one the relay
in time for the double play
and a quick return from tahedah it
wasn't even close at first two on with
two outs jared walsh who batted the
number five spot today walsh drives one
out to right field gallow is going to
watch this one go big fly for jared
walsh and the angels have a
three-nothing lead jumped all over that
2-1 pitch that is the best play in
baseball a three-run home run for jared
walsh the right-hander dylan bundy who's
having a very nice season bundy is ready
faces tavares
and he hits this ball sharply out to
right field that's a base hit and that
could be good for two bases
maybe more he's into second he'll turn
and try for three and there will be no
relay a triple for tavares to start the
bottom of the first and o'dore banning
second today
it's this one on the ground down to
first spinning move by walsh
and they get odor but he'll bring in a
run tavares in from third and it's a 3-1
ball
game out to the man in third base now
and simmons at the plate
and he swings and misses here that
strikeout the final out of the inning so
the angels will leave a man at third
he's not at first base pretty decent
lead but he's not going anywhere and
trout
in the air out to right field gallow
back does he have room he does and he
makes the catch
and now hustles it back to first in time
for the double play
wow another missile from that right
field corner from joey gallo to go on
handles with three the top of the first
texas responded with one of the bottom
of the first mathis strikes out for the
first down second punch down for dylan
bundy that's that's swinging miss slider
for bundy and now tavares will be the
next batter two two
called strike three rings them up on the
inside part of the play tavares doesn't
like the call that was a change up as
well back to back strikeouts two outs so
at the plate was odor with the runner at
second but two outs oh two
door foul tips out into the mid and
bundy strikes out the side they leave
the runner in second at the plate for
the angels is jared walsh
wall shoots this one toward the right
field corner gallo moving over and that
is a fair ball
walsh on his way to second he's going to
try to go to third
the throw from gallows off line and
jared walsh has a whole home run in last
night's game and picks up a triple here
oh he's on his way to the cycle you got
the two hardest ones out of the way
early home run and a triple the bases
are loaded and he fo the batter he's old
for one
bouncer up the middle could be two they
get to one at second and the fire over
to first in time for the double play
there's that rocket arm again from
tahedah to get the twin killing and the
inning is done so here's gallow who
grounded out his first time up gallows
strikes out to away fastball from dylan
bundy bundy's got it going right now he
looks good today
got him looking he's got the punch out
working now dylan bundy bundy right now
has racked up some strikeouts he has
struck out five of the last six batters
throws only 11 pitches shot at a single
in his first day be a fly ball to right
field the third
that is hammered out to left field what
were you saying that's his second in
texas
and it extends the angels lead to 4-1 he
went down and got that one lower part of
the strike so never a good idea against
trout 16th home run of the season for
trouty so dylan bundy is ready his o2
delivery and that is on the outside
corner and out looking is dietrich and
that's another strikeout for bundy and
another batteries retired in a row
mijada has a single his only time up
good morning good afternoon and good
night to anderson tajeda so another
clean inning with another
two strikeouts the last three innings he
struck out three two and two more
2-2 pitch
and that one
out to odor nice play
so here's simmons batting now with two
outs
hard hit the left center field of base
hit this could possibly score taylor
ward zolac gets the baseball back in
ward being waved around and he will
score it's five to one good base running
as angel the simmons that's up at second
base with the rbi
63 pitches for bundy in this game faces
the leadoff batter the nine-hole hitter
jeff matheson
mathis goes down swing third consecutive
strikeout for dylan bundy ninth overall
one else would win at third max stassi
is the better now the payoff from herd
stassi rips without the left center
field tavares moving over and that'll
goes as sac flies rindone will easily
score from third six to one angels
situational hitting there by stassi well
kind of felefa leading off this seventh
inning
there's a base hit for kinder felefa and
so it's a 13-game hitting streak for him
joey galloway for two
got him upstairs in the fastball
strikeout number 10 for dylan bundy
second time he's got him in the fastball
so a base runner anderson to hay to one
of the other ones he had the base hit in
the third two two
and this ball hit hard out to the alley
right field it gets down base hit
dietrich streaming to third base they'll
wave him to the plate
zaheda going for three and he's in with
a triple
second triple the ball game for the
rangers
and they cut the lead to four
mike myers takes over on the mound
and that's out toward left center field
trout
and roared and slices toward ward and
that'll be the third out now the rangers
are down to their final out in this ball
game so at the plate is guzman
and he got him away light that baby up
as the angels pick up the victory this
afternoon by the final of six to two